he's a great husband he's a great father
he's a great guy yeah Kelly Ripa loves
hubby Mark Consuelos almost as much as
she enjoys to call him out I counter
troll with love the morning show host
shared a personal response to this
headline on social media what is the one
thing that your partner said that really
helped you through your birth experience
well as she recalls Mark once asked her
quote do you mind if I eat and at some
point he said quote I'm going to the
batting cages since you're going to be
here a while read the delivery rule Mark
read the delivery room do not
unsolicited Regale a first-time mom with
stories they couldn't find the men that
gave me the epidural he went missing and
then I got a headache and my husband
left to get a sandwich people would say
to us oh don't blink because they grow
up before you know it but we did we
blinked unfortunately and now they are
grown adults yeah the a-listers are mom
and dads whose Sons Michael and Joaquin
and daughter Lola we met on set I had a
screen test and then what happened
and then you begged me to marry you and
then we went to Las Vegas and got
married and didn't tell anybody for a
few months and then we found out we were
pregnant all jokes aside Mark's gone
above and beyond in the past like maybe
walking barefoot out of the hospital
after uh they they take out the baby and
you think that you're going to put on
your your regular clothes again your
jeans and I actually wound up leaving
the hospital much bigger than what I was
right I was like how is this even
possible and I was wearing uh I was
wearing
um my husband's shoes out of the
hospital because my feet were so swollen
I couldn't fit into my own shoes he's a
great father he's a great guy and Kelly
thanks so much of her hubby he even got
a special shout out in her Memoir
Livewire I think of like most of this
book as a love letter to mark That's why
I dedicated the book to him because he
really has walked through
you know mo most of my adult life with
me he's a great friend that's the
greatest thing he is a friend and if you
have him as a friend you've hit the
jackpot
[Music]